[Music]
in edible cotton news Oh interesting
mic on can I get a double cab yeah
submitted by please come to India no
tips going by yourself see you there
Tiffin KC Mumbai bye bye I'm pretty sure
there's a lot of beautiful places but my
Indian friends tell me not to go I'm
probably not gonna go no they told you
that yeah
don't go that's my introduction for one
if you go so they make me feel stupid
for wanting to go I'm like I probably
you know well the USDA has approved the
production of genetically modified
cotton seed for human consumption
whoa this is random what does this mean
random for us but they've actually been
working on this for many decades
well we actually use cottonseed oil for
cooking so we do use cottonseed oil but
like cottonseed itself it's actually
toxic mm-hmm because it produces this
toxin called gloss simple and what it
does it it lowers blood potassium to
dangerous levels and if that results in
fatigue and even paralysis or you can't
eat eat it by itself cause it's toxic
but then now they're saying that they've
genetically engineered these seeds to be
safe for human consumption why would
they do this because in the past they've
genetically engineered cottonseed to
have it without this toxin but when they
it doesn't have this toxin then the
crops get eaten by bugs or other animals
and I think it's a Brahmin but then now
they've genetically engineered it
because they're saying that cottonseed
is very high in protein and nearly 20
million farmers in 80 countries many of
those have high rates of malnutrition
they can see this as a solution because
if people eat it then they can have the
basic protein requirements cool so now
they can get close and eat it - exactly
hmm yeah because they're saying that all
the chicken eggs produce in the world
right now which is 1.4 trillion
couldn't meet the protein in what's
being producing cottonseed it's like a
big deal it could help world hunger we
have so much food in this world man we
can't we can't share it with people
there's a lot of waste so much [ __ ]
waste man is so sad especially on the
film industry oh the restaurant yeah you
restaurant scary I think we all are
guilty in all sense really I mean that's
why one of our goals like the plate I
had an extra issue I seen everything
then I would have your food my food
their food everybody's food that's why
one of our goals is waste control for
our all of our shops that's tight
yeah cuz we want to keep it out of
minimum and figure out a better more
eco-friendly way yeah yeah it's hard
it's hard because what's happening now
is we only have X amount of space to
grow [ __ ] right but most of it is being
grown on cash crops which is corn soy
and I think I forgot we so for cereals
and [ __ ] like that and then the corn is
either for eating or like we grow that
corn so are like livestock can eat it or
for like ethanol and [ __ ] like that but
it's subsidized by the government so
these guys don't really need to make
like bank or anything as long as they
grow they get paid so yeah it's kind of
its kind of [ __ ] up cuz we need more
space for like actual like [ __ ] that we
can eat like vegetables and good food
but they're [ __ ] farming the [ __ ] out
of it and then like their chemical and
lysing that [ __ ] so hard that
the soil is starting to burn out so it's
like I don't know what we're gonna do
we're all gonna die so it's like that
interstellar problem we're like the
earth yeah we gotta figure out a
solution for sure I start peeing back
into the soil I take a [ __ ] into the
soil back again oh no we don't have to
do that we got it no reefer ttle eyes
the earth you used to do that and I'm
glad you don't it and it one of those
the sweetest oranges you've ever ate
they were pretty smooth pretty they're
pretty good is I pissed off walk out of
those just flesh on number two and not
one
yeah so we got to do and no one does no
one's gonna do that well I think we also
do we just have a lot of like
first-world like things that we do here
that we don't even realize like if you
go to a restaurant and you have
leftovers and you leave it on the table
that's the first one yeah yeah that's a
huge [ __ ] first wolf thing I do that
all the time well not anymore yeah so
like even don't need out anymore yeah
those like first of all things that we
do that's something very small but it's
huge like people don't even realize they
say that you literally left the whole
[ __ ] meal on the table and you just
walked away from it like it's nothing
not only that but like when you're
watching dishes and you just leave that
thing oh yeah like watch that yeah like
that and I think like for so people it's
just like you're so used to just doing
it that way that it's okay but if the
food wasn't scarcity you would never
even think about doing that [ __ ] even
even just all the just the amount of
increase in takeout you know with all
the posts mates wave you know how much
like plastic and styrofoam all that is
is I crazy I'm talking like I don't post
mates like three times a day like cuz I
save the ones that I want to use because
I feel bad throwing it away so I'm like
I just have a [ __ ] ton don't give you a
styrofoam box do this carry the pancake
in their hands that is Admiral what I
should ask for no utensils but I feel
like I usually get mad if they'd forget
that yeah I mean I get I mean I guess I
should learn how to cook it would help
more yeah sure you could eat healthier
that's what is it cheaper now yeah it's
actually cheap it's really yeah yeah if
you cook right like if you cook for the
week or whatever but if you're like
buying specific ingredients for that
meal you got to go out and buy no that's
gonna be more expensive if you never
cook before the first load is gonna be a
lot because you have to buy all the
seasonings that's the expensive [ __ ]
right there
yeah and not only that too like people
people your food is expensive when you
cook at home because you're trying to
cook 18 different things at once yeah
which requires way too many [ __ ]
products and on top of that too like who
you're not you're gonna buy six [ __ ]
hamburger buns are you gonna eat [ __ ]
six hamburgers within this next week
you're not they don't want to eat this
this and that and most people
they cook at home they're not eating
eighteen different things around a week
usually the same [ __ ] right because you
know food is supposed to be processed
but if you do eat the six hamburgers and
preachy probably yeah always there's a
market that sells just one that'd be
[ __ ] dope you know one thing but you
can't yeah six of em right right and did
you end up wasting because they don't
run through money in time before it
expires right saying yeah exactly so
like the other day I got like some some
chicken and I wanted to just wrap it up
in a tortilla he's either with salsa but
I got the pack and it was buy one get
one free so now I have 60 tortillas but
those buy one get one free
I know hey guys let me spend more money
yeah that is true though I guess that's
the reason because people want to sell
more for it's all money it's not money
base it's like so much [ __ ] carpets
tortillas they don't even good dude I'm
just looking at them dude what Brandon
yeah brother it was some knockoff brand
oh that's even worse it was just so
cheap and they're like you know those
like cheap like soft floured put the
flour tortillas yeah like the ones like
the mission ones that are super soft
you tried to mission the Dare Street
taco soft flour ones those are [ __ ]
good they're like a little cloud it's
like a little cloud I like the ones that
they're kind of doughy and then you put
it on a pan and then you can make it
it's kind of fresh they got those like
par par cooked tortillas too like where
they halfway cook it and you just finish
it on yeah yeah those are good oh man
tortillas are you guys who's cooking for
who cooks for you guys Thanksgiving oh
yeah what's your plan whoever goes to
you guy whose house are we going to his
old family house is too small you're
trying to bigger house you can buy
people over Wow sound way to stand with
this conversation you don't invite us in
about the dude
I'll kickin it with my friends oh no no
I mean I'm saying I wouldn't like I'm
not the host
you know me I'm you the guy that goes -
yeah exactly I don't think any of us in
this room are the HOS oh yeah
I used to be really yeah remember we had
yet Thanksgiving there we had a better
house we have people arriving my own
utensils though
it's so big a fit they fit like so many
people and it felt like still breathing
I mean yeah cuz we have a similar place
and where you used to live so like we
have a lot of like no no I'm talking
about the we T er house that was my
bedroom BAM that's true open space and
you don't feel crammed I always had the
good Thanksgiving food dude I [ __ ]
hate it
it's [ __ ] sucks oh really you're the
dude yeah because like even this
conversation is creating my mom but you
cook good though yeah but it takes
[ __ ] three days that's your fault
don't regard to your house now you guys
get if you want to cook more you can
back home know we're here what do you do
like the friendsgiving thing and you
cook away like for the family family
like my mom called me and she goes so
what are we having for Thanksgiving [ __ ]
what do you mean what we aren't you
cooking she's like no you're cooking no
no you got down like that that was [ __ ]
you have the whole [ __ ] washcloth on
his thing it takes that long cuz you're
doing it alone you made puta G you're
supposed to like you're supposed to do
things giving like with a team with your
family only work on one day but every
time I have people help me out I always
turns like [ __ ] I want people touch my
[ __ ] so you complain I just want to do
it at all they don't even last
Thanksgiving we bought a turkey that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] trashed it was a couple
things give me a go or although bad dude
so make are all turkey I'll bring the hi
know you have two men I'm a just
something I'm actually gonna I'm going
to break down the turkey this time and
actually the Soviet
so we're gonna try something a little
different I think that's your pointing
out a reason why we're so wasteful and
all this [ __ ] is because we don't have
time so people that can figure out how
to be more convenient for us will pay
for that [ __ ]
well it will make ill on musk figure
this [ __ ] yeah man yeah let the smart
people deal with going after him dude
he's like our [ __ ] Savior I think
that they are going after him
no no don't fix the world problem want a
solar panel in my house right now yeah
you want us to kill this earth because
it makes them money well we need to have
things give me so we don't think about
that
Thanksgiving is literally the most
wasteful holiday out of everything all
the leftovers it's damn near pile but we
shouldn't be eating that much to begin
with like well we need to like fatten up
for the winner dude yeah like five five
minutes into this thing under camera
environmentalists and your [ __ ]
searchers the hemp
[Music]